we're finally well and truly in the
topic of calculus right and one of the
crucial initial questions is how do you
use what you've just learned to be able
to find these particular objects because
they're very important to us as you'll
continue to see tangents you've heard of
we're talking about changes yesterday
tangents are those lines straight lines
that do what to a curve they just touch
right they don't cut across they just
touch it then they continue going okay a
better definition for a tangent a more
concrete definition now the gullible
language for it is it's a line that
shares the same gradient as a curve
where they intersect let me say that
again in fact I'll write it down a
tangent is a line it's a straight line
that shares the same gradient
as the curve that is just touching okay
at that point at the point that it
touches
so that's what a tangent is will come to
this other idea in a second let's just
get the tension on the board shall we
I've gone ahead and I've done a bit of
drawing because I've looked at this
function I thought I can factorize this
when you do factorize it what do you get
X minus 1 X minus 2 which is why you can
see I have strategically placed my
parabola down here when it's intercept
at 1 & 2 where the tangent look like at
or when x equals 1 where you can see
where x equals 1 is down there right so
I'm looking for a line that just touches
the parabola right there okay grab your
ruler out this is a bit tricky I want to
try and do this but I hope I don't
accidentally rub off my ball at the same
time
so grab your or there actually this will
probably do you know that will give me a
long rough line and with your ruler
nestled up against the curve against the
parabola so that you're happy with it
being tangential at the point that we're
interested in at when x equals 1 so I
think I'm pretty happy with that
now yeah
and I didn't rub off too much of the
curse at the same time which is always a
bonus so this guy here is the tangent
mmm okay now we have an idea of that we
know also how to find that but straight
away the question is also asking us for
this second object a normal a normal is
just like a tangent in that it's also a
straight line but it's not it doesn't
have the same gradient as the curve in
fact it has a perpendicular gradient to
the curve so it's at right angles with
the tangent you might like to label that
I'm going to put it in green because I'm
going to draw my normal in green the
normal is perpendicular to the tangent
so what would that look like on ours
well you're going to come slice across
at right angles so I'm guessing I'm
going to grab my ruler out again because
I don't trust myself
I'm guessing it's going to look
something like that
a novel can cut the grass more than once
as you can see if I continued extended
that green line which I'm going to label
it normal now the normal can cut the
grass more than once and in fact as I'll
show you later on tangents can to
tangents actually can intersect with a
graph more than once but at a particular
spot they will share the gradient let me
just quickly show you what I mean before
we move on to the nuts and bolts of this
question and this is where throwing off
on the side just draw like a little set
actually something like that and what
I'd like you to do is draw for me a
cubic curve instead of a parabola which
is a quadratic so it might look
something like this now this is a pretty
common curve to have a look at and I
want you to recognize the fact that
actually it's quite easy for a tangent
to intersect that curve more than once
for example there's a tangent right
where is that black line where is it
tangent to the curve it's tended to be
kind of at this one over here whatever
that happens to be right and you can see
they share the same gradient at that
point but it just keeps on going on its
merry way and slices the curve again
after a problem it's just that this line
is not tangent here edit page it here
because cool seem to deal with the
normal by the way when this continues
going it's not going to be at right
angles to this part of a curve it's only
at right angles down here at the
particular spot that we specify okay all
right so now that we know what a teacher
to normal are we can go ahead and find
them because they're just straight lines
like all the other ones we've been
dealing with think about the tangent
I've got to point to you by the way now
that I know that they're written to one
other coordinates at that point 1 comma
0 so I'll just go 1 comma 0 if you've
got a point that's on the line
you only need one other piece of
information to work out its equation in
this case gradient because again the
gradient is what we know it's what makes
this
special if we want to know the gradient
at that point what are we gonna have to
do we're going to need to find a
gradient function we're gonna have the
differentiate so let's go ahead and do
that if Y is equal to that which form
I've shown you a couple of forms from
writing the derivative I should use
dy/dx right I suppose you are you could
write Y - if you'd like but I've already
given the reasons why I'm not keen on
that notation if you said y equals f of
X then you could have gone f dash X and
I think that's when you see f of X you
see the function notation it's a lot
it's a lot easier to recognize oh that's
a - I know what that is but thing is
we've already got a why I'm just going
to rub with this okay have a look you've
got one two three terms each of which
you can find the derivative of
independently which is nice x squared do
you remember our rule for
differentiation I can do yeah the two is
going to come out the front right that
power will come out the front and then
what happens to the power it drops down
by one which makes it one so I'm not
going to write it okay what about this
this is also power of X it's some it's a
1 so what will happen yeah so that one
is going to come out the front which
produces no change but then the power is
going to drop down by one it's going to
go from 1 to 0 which means you just end
up with the minus 3 yeah last big have a
look at this guy right
to turn what do we do with the
derivative that so I want you to think I
want you to think about what y equals
just 2 y equals 2 what did that line
look like well y equals 2 is something
like this right Y was - it's a
horizontal line what is the gradient of
a horizontal line there's no right
there's lots of runs but is the rise of
0 over whatever right so therefore the
two doesn't contribute anything to the
derivative just ends up being zero so
I'm done that's the derivative ok so now
I can say when
x equals 1 now what I'm about to do just
for the sake of completeness because
this is an important example I'm going
to find the y coordinate now in this
case the y corner happen to be easy to
see because it was a root but if I'd
given you any other x value except for
two okay you're gonna have to find out
where those coordinates are and say when
x equals 1 y equals and then you're
going to have to substitute into here
right we already know this so I'm just
going to say one consumer when x equals
1 also do y on DX I can evaluate it at
that point right so I'm just going to
substitute x equals 1 into the
derivative so what do you get 2 minus 3
which is negative 1 you happy with that
so therefore I'm going to say the
gradient of the tangent I'm not going to
say M by itself because I'm about to in
about three minutes find out another
gradient so I'm going to label the
gradient that I'm dealing with the
grading of the tangents that
so therefore the equation of the tangent
is and then I'm going to watch into
which four point great it cuz I got a
point got a grade so Y minus 0 equals
okay what do you think are you happy not
bad considering I did a lot of that by
hand y equals minus X plus 1 looks
pretty convincing to me
please note by the way I think it's
really important for you to say this not
just because we're about to find a new
equation in a second I want to just have
two random equations sitting there but I
want you to communicate why are you
doing this next view why is that there
please don't go straight from there to
there because the logic is not clea
you're not communicating that in an
obvious way now I'm ready to move on to
find this thing it's perpendicular so
what I know about the gradient it will
be the negative reciprocal of this
gradient right so I'm going to say the
gradient of the normal is going to be
the negative reciprocal
this right minus one over that which is
also minus one okay which is one which
confirms this decent diagram that we
also drew before okay I've got a new
gradient but I don't need to find
another point why not it goes through
the same point is the teja that's kind
of point of this right so therefore I'm
going to say the equation of the normal
and then I'm just going to launch into
point gradient again happy times so it's
not really complicated but you've got to
know where you're going you've got to
know what do I need to find the equation
of this line two pieces I'll need in
addition to this x coordinate or y
coordinate and then you're going to need
to know a grade here because that's the
important thing about a tangent and a
normal in questions
yep yeah sure it's easy enough to change
this question very subtly let's say find
the equation of the tangent in the
normal to the same curve at when x
equals three
it's not that complicated to do so I'm
going to find the derivative again
because I still need to know the
gradient eventually but instead of going
through this I'm going to say when x
equals what'd I just say three right why
is then now I have to go ahead and work
this out because I have no idea what
coordinate that will be let's see four -
what'd I just say that'll be nine plus
two if I done it right did I try it yes
I'm sorry I'm squaring yeah that's right
equals two because I'm squaring three
okay so you've got a now you've got a
different X&Y coordinate and you're
going to have to find a new gradient at
that point okay I like to distinguish
between their gradient function and the
gradient at a particular spot or a
particular feature okay so you see why
our DX for the function itself which
change depending on what x you'd like
and then these guys on the other hand
biggest numbers because it's a great at
a certain spot then we go